so a couple videos ago i did a majora's
mask theory that was really just a
question to my fan base on whether i
should include termina as legitimate
zelda lore for future videos
and you guys answered with a pretty
resounding yes
because of that answer this video is
made possible so
i hope all of you watching this are
excited for what i have to say
because after all you were the
inspiration isn't it great when you find
something in a zelda game that expounds
on stuff from previous
zelda games just really makes the
theorist in you happy you know
well as many many fans know by now the
most recent game breath of the wild is
chock full of these kinds of easter eggs
and landmarks that sometimes very
explicitly point towards the zelda games
that have been released
previously like the literal ruins of the
ranch from ocarina of time that long
time fans will know as long lawn ranch
or the great bridge of hylia which is in
some places almost the spitting
image of the bridge of hylia from
twilight princess or the castletown
fountain that again
is very closely resembling the
castletown fountain from twilight
princess and perhaps even ocarina of
time
but you have to ask the question
especially with a wild game like breath
of the wild
how much of all of this stuff is you
know canon
like we know that at least more than 10
000 years have passed since the events
that we're playing through in breath of
the wild's present day
think about that that's older than the
entire written history of humanity
so how could the temple of time still be
standing for instance
is this literally the same temple from
ocarina of time that was just kept up
with all these years or a different
temple entirely that merely resembles
the original one
in other words is this stuff real or
simply a shout out that's meant as sort
of a fourth wall break also known as an
easter egg but isn't actually canon the
same goes for some of the dlc items
obtained like the majora's mask
or the castle town or even this rock
carving of darmani who is a goron hero
that hails from the mysterious land of
termina which should have no connection
to hyrule's history here but yet like
many other strange appearances in breath
of the wild
here he stands well due to the nature of
this game and the lore behind zelda
these questions can be answered using a
lot of speculation
so let's speculate why don't we in the
first place i'd like to point out that i
think some of these references are
non-canon and some
are canon just to you know make things a
little more confusing and i'm not gonna
go over every single reference in breath
of the wild that's iffy
but i will give a couple examples of the
differences real quick let me put it
this way
in breath of the wild how much sense
does it make for the majora's mask to be
randomly found in a chest within some
riverside ruins
i'm talking the majora's mask that's
still glowing with power somehow
even after the events of the game
majora's mask where at the end the mask
is shown as
powerless that to me is an example of a
simple easter egg that doesn't affect
breath of the wild canon
a non-zelda example from another very
recent and popular game would be this
toad here trying to climb this wall from
paper mario the origami king
what this toad says is a clear reference
to breath of the wild but does that mean
that oh this takes place in the same
universe and link and zelda's
descendants are somewhere out there
or maybe that zelda is a video game in
the mario universe that toad plays all
the time
well no i think everyone agrees that
this is an example of just a simple
shout out or easter egg and doesn't
actually mean anything as far as lore is
concerned
some things in breath of the wild fall
into this category but
others in my opinion can be considered
actual canon depending on how you
translate it for instance
the temple of time is in my opinion the
actual temple from ocarina of time and
sure it may have just been kept up with
all these years but how can it be the
same one if it's so far from the castle
you ask
well actually if you're interested in my
full theory that a lot of these land
masses may have shifted around in breath
of the wild's hyrule check out the
theory i did with nintendo black crisis
on hyrule's moving castle i'll link to
it in the description below anyway i
tend to believe that when you have
literal landmarks or land masses that
are giant
similarities or direct references to
previous zelda games they're probably
the real deal
like death mountain i don't think there
are multiple death mountains
i'm pretty sure that one there is the
only one that's ever been
so using my own sort of criteria for
what it is and is not canon in the game
what about this statue of darmani canon
or non-canon and
for those who are unfamiliar with who
darmani is i'll summarize real quick
in the rather dark and depressing game
majora's mask link travels to the
mysterious land of termina
and there meets several key characters
who are all either dead or
dying so that he can get masks from them
and use their powers to complete the
temples of the game
good stuff good stuff but one of these
dying characters is the beloved goron
hero darmani who link finds as already
having died
but struggling with the fact so link
ends up healing darmani's soul with the
song of healing which allows him to
accept his death and move on
and then link is able to grab darmani's
freshly made goron mask
all well and good but that happened
within the land of termina
and this statue here is in hyrule so
canon or non-canon
i say it's canon because it's not the
only statue in goron city
there's also daruk from this very game
who i'm pretty sure
is canon and the goron elder from
twilight princess who is definitely a
part of hyrule's history
carved into the very map of breath of
the wild
so logically speaking if we dismissed
the statue of darmani we'd have to
dismiss the statue of daruk as well
and claim that this literal section of
hyrule's map is non-canon which we have
no reason for doing in my opinion
all of these statues were made by gorons
in reference to their legends and
are canon and yes this has implications
for the timeline placement but i'm not
talking about that in this video if
darmani's statue is canon that means
that
somehow these hyrulean gorons have
actual memories and legends of the
terminian gorons and this is impossible
since termina is an alternate reality
right
i mean it's not even the same world
right well what if
it's not another world at all but rather
just another land in the same world of
hyrule
alright fasten your seat belts it's
about to get really good have you ever
asked yourself why we
assume termina is a parallel world well
it's probably because of the 3d assets
they used for their characters
lots of them are the same ones from
ocarina of time and i'll admit
i used to assume it was a parallel world
because of this too pretty recently
but we can't do that because the only
reason some of the assets from ocarina
of time are used for some of the
characters
is because majora's mask was a rushed
title that nintendo wanted to release
before the announcement of the gamecube
reusing assets for this was completely
understandable and i mean it's not like
they didn't
also include several completely original
characters in the game
like tingle by the way which wouldn't be
possible if it was an actual parallel
world
there are also no parallel landmarks
anywhere term in a field is
nothing like hyrule field for instance
an example of an
actual parallel world would be laurel
from a link between worlds which mimics
the exact
map and landmarks of hyrule from a link
to the past so am i saying that since
termina is not a different world at all
it actually exists
in the same world just physically
removed from hyrule by some great
distance
yes that's exactly what i'm saying now
to prove it
let's take a look at how link enters
termina yes it's a trippy fall down a
hollowed-out tree that feels very much
like a portal but that's just it
i do believe it is a portal that's no
different than the other portals already
present in the woods
look the lost woods is a magical place
where people can literally
infinitely get turned around and around
and around
until they're lost forever and even
sometimes turn into monsters and it's
also a place where literal magical
portals link to places like goron city
and zora's domain
so why not also a portal that links to
termina a place
just as physically real as goron city or
zora's domain and as far as the theory
that termina is not physically real and
simply a creation of the power of majora
how then does it still exist after
majora's defeat and removal of power
at the end of the game shouldn't the
world have immediately crumbled into
non-existence like coho lint island did
when the wind fish woke up
there are even some evidences of
possible majora influence bleeding over
into hyrule's history like the
well-known eyes on midna's fused shadow
helmet thing or twilight princess
ganondorf's original armor design
these design choices have led many to
believe that the creators of the fused
shadow
also known as the interlopers and the
ancient tribe that created the majora's
mask could possibly be one and the same
and i'm not gonna go into that anymore
but if that's true it would obviously
mean termina is a real place
accessible from the lost woods
furthermore in a land that features
no landmarks from hyrule why would a
goron directly reference
hyrule's dadango's cavern from ocarina
of time unless they do
exist in the same world and that's the
actual dodongo's cavern they're
referencing
the final piece of evidence for terminus
existence is
the dharmani sculpture since it's made
from the minds of gorons and gorons are
canon
that has to mean that not only is
termina an actual real place
but the gorons from termina either in
part or holy came
over at some point to join their
hyrulian brothers maybe they even came
through the lost woods portals who knows
and when they arrived
their histories and legends now became
one and the same
either way i believe that's the story
behind this statue
i believe it proves that termina is a
real
place and that is just my theory but
what did you guys think you think i'm
onto something or is this literally a
non-canon piece of rock that doesn't
actually exist
let me know in the comments below thank
you all so much for watching
i really hope you enjoyed the video if
you did please consider subscribing to
help the channel grow and leaving a like
to help the video grow as always
huge thanks goes to all of my amazing
supporters introducing
several new names say hello to justin l
josh
a puppet of fate luna hellweg and
michael g
who all decided to become my elite crew
and support the channel
if you're interested in getting your
name up here at the end of each of my
videos and helping my next video come to
life
check out that join button located below
this video or the links in the
description below
also down there are of course the links
to my social media pages so hey
come connect with me and say hi on
twitter this is maskingtonabandit
signing out and hoping that you have a
great rest of your day peace
[Music]
you